- Today I'm super excited
because my best friend
and fellow 25 year old from college, Kate,
finally saved enough
money to come visit me.
She's a Lyft driver and
a part-time stand up
and she's pretty funny.
- Almost got hit by a
Bently on my way here,
maybe next time, right?
They're expensive.
Are you guys awake?
- And I swear she's funny,
well she's a really good Lyft driver.
(knocking)
- Hello!
- Hi!
♫ Let's drink ♫
- I have to use your bathroom
real quick, is Paul home?
- No, he went skateboarding.
We don't get to see each other often,
but when we do it's like
we're 20 again, almost.
- Do you really think
these fake IDs will work?
- Definitely, plus we all look over 21.
- This will be fun to watch.
(upbeat music)
- ID, you're good.
- What's going on Ben?
- Just letting underage girls
in, wishing for the best.
Have a good one.
- God, he's taking forever.
- This guy sucks at his job.
- Seriously.
- Aw, poor Henry, he's
all by himself tonight.
- Poor guy.
- It's about time.
- What can I get you guys?
[All] - Cosmos!
- Hey.
- Sorry for the wait you guys.
- Henry, do not even apologize, okay.
- Does this outfit look okay?
- Yeah, so cute.
- Look at my boobs in this shirt.
- Girls, look at them.
- They are some beautiful men.
- Hello.
- Look at these d-bag holders.
(giggling)
- That ones haircut is controlling him.
(laughing)
- I'm going to go say, "Hi."
- Text before you go home with anyone.
- Yeah.
- Uh oh, this one's going to go say, "Hi."
- But he's gay.
- He's gay.
- Oh my gosh girl, how'd it go?
- It was amazing,
he says he's not looking
for anything right now
but he invited us all
to go out rock climbing
with him and his friend tomorrow.
- Ooo
- So adventurous.
- Yeah.
- They're going to make such a cute couple
when they come out.
- Reminds me of my first
boyfriend, remember Jeff?
- Oh yeah I remember,
he's a cool theater major.
- Brian, Matthew, Steven.
- Bree, Mancheko, Swiss, baby.
- My Bio class is so dumb,
it's like I'm not going to be a Biologist,
I'm going into advertising.
Well, like Matt Penn.
- Fuck student loans.
- For real.
- Gosh, my mom's so annoying.
- Moms are crazy.
- She's calling me now.
- How's your mom doing?
- She's so good.
- Aw.
- Yeah.
[Together] - I need to borrow
someone's Netflix password.
- You can use mine.
- Oh cool, thank you.
- You can have my mom's.
- 30 is technically still so young.
- You're right.
- 30's just too old, though.
- So many wrinkles.
- Alright, let's close out,
I got to work in the A.M.
Can we get the check Henry?
Thank you.
- Thank you.
- Woo, I love this place!
- Let's get drunk!
- Hoo, hoo, hoo!
(upbeat music)
- Oh, oh, oh!